in medical news a new study has started
a debate about colonoscopies long
regarded as a gold standard of screening
for colorectal cancer the study
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine found that participants who
were offered a colonoscopy at only 18
percent lower rates of colon cancer
researchers say those patients had about
the same risk of death from the disease
10 years down the line CBS News chief
medical correspondent that's Dr John
LaPook is with us he's a
gastroenterologist
you're my doctor so I even know all of
this but listen this is certainly your
area of expertise the headlines can be
very jarring what's your take right I
think the headlines are misleading big
study one group was just followed the
other group was offered a colonoscopy
you heard about the statistics after 10
years about an 18 decrease in the risk
of getting colon cancer but no
difference in mortality but
only 42 percent of the people offered a
colonoscopy actually got it of the
people who got the colonoscopy there was
a 31 decreased risk of colon cancer over
to about 10 years and a 50 decrease in
the in the Mortal risk of mortality risk
of dying from colon cancer so a lot of
numbers there though John okay so bottom
line it for us I mean if somebody is
thinking well now I don't really need to
do it or I'm reluctant to get it what do
you say get it this still is the gold
standard you know it's not enough to be
offered a colonoscopy or offered a test
you have to actually do the test yeah
now I spoke to the author who was in
Norway a lot of statistical issues and
to we can we can go over these fancy
schmancy analysis okay was it long
enough 10 years to see a benefit in
terms of mortality were the
colonoscopies good enough the people who
did the colonoscopy be good enough at
picking up polyps and things like that
but the bottom line is a colonoscopy is
a great way the best way we know of
preventing colon cancer you know you go
in there I've done many many thousands
of them you find a polyp and that polyp
has the potential to turn into colon
cancer over time you take away that
polyp you remove it and instead of
potentially getting colon cancer you
don't get colon cancer quickly what's
the age you should get it first
screening at 45 if you're at average
risk and if you're at increased risk uh
lower than that talk to your doctor
about your health care professional
about exactly the timing Dr John lapo we
appreciate you giving us the bottom line
of pun intended thank you so much